على ما يبدو مشاهدينا هنا فرق الانقاذ
تنتشر احد الضحايا في مدينه
اديمان التركيه اذا ساترك الصوره تتكلم
واعود
[موسيقى]
بالي بالي
على ما يبدو مشاهدينا بهذه الصوره نرى
يعني
المصل ما يعرف بالمصل الطبي يتم مد لاحد
الناجين تحت الانقاض والذي تتم بهذه
الاثناء وبهذه اللحظات عمليه انقاذه من
تحت هذه الانقاض بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب هذه المنطقه منذ صباح الاثنين
وحتى اليوم طبعا اليوم يعني من صمد تحت
الانقاذ بكل هذه الظروف الصعبه اصبح يعتبر
انشاء نحن دخلنا اليوم الرابع
وسندخل يعني غدا اليوم الخامس وهو ما
يعتبر اننا دخلنا بالمرحله الحرجه وكل
ساعه تاخير تعني خساره مزيد من الارواح
وتضائل الفرص بالعثور على الناجين طبعا
الفرق الطبيه هناك والفرق الانقاذ اقوم
بجهود جباره
لمحاوله انتشال قدر المستطاع ويعني القيام
بما باقصى ما يمكن ان يقام به ولكن طبعا
الكارثه كبيره عدد المباني هائله ونحن
نتحدث عن كارثه غير مسبوقه في التاريخ
التركي ربما في العام 18
بهذا الوقت حصل شيء مشابه ولكن اليوم
نتحدث عن اضرار كبيره عن خسائر بشريه
وايضا خسائر
يعني
بالمباني وبالطرقات وهو ما يصعب عمليه
الوصول الى بعض المناطق وعمليه الانقاص
طبعا وعلاوه على كل ذلك ايضا الظروف
المناخيه والظروف الطبيعيه لهذه المناطق
على ما يبدو
تم يعني تم انتشال شخص من تحت الانقاض وتم
انقاذ احد
المواطنين الاتراك من تحت الانقاذ ويتم
عمليه تتم عمليه اغاثه بهذه الاسنان وطبعا
اعطاءه الاسعافات الاوليه القيام
بالاسعافات الاوليه المطلوبه لنقل طبعا
الى المستشفى او اي المراكز الطبيه
الميدانيه التي اقيمت هناك بظل اقتضاض
المشافي وطبعا المراكز الميدانيه على امل
ان يكون بصحه جيده وان يعني تزداد الحالات
المشابهه التي يمكن القول بانهم ناجين
طيله هذا المساء وطيله عمليه البحث
والانقاذ حتى لا نخسر ارواح اكثر بهذا
الزلزال المدمر